to spend a bunch of time underwater
which was a grueling difficult
challenging process rings of power has
proven to be an insanely difficult show
to produce we did a lot of stunt
training and fight training which all
bled into not only for the actors but
for the stunt performers the crew and
the visual effects team have you been
wondering what kind of chaos was going
on behind the scenes well we've got
answers for you it would be challenging
by the end of the day number one it can
be hard to remember every single one the
cast had many weeks to prepare so most
of the time they had all of their lines
down pat but of course there's always
bound to be a few mistakes I think
everyone also did occasionally forget
their lines morphid Clark wasn't the
only one to forget a few lines here and
there but one day while working a scene
with Charlie she had to do a lot more
takes than usual I wasn't actually
forgetting the lines but I was doing
slightly different words for every
single line there must have been
something in the air that day so I had
to say scattered and I'd say scrambled
and I was like oh no number two there
was always something being pulled
amongst the cast there's always like
joking around and pulling pranks Maxim
baldry Takes the Cake for the best prank
pulled on set he pretended to get hurt
on set one day and filmed it not like
there weren't enough actual injuries
going on more on that later it's like
poor crew member thought he'd like he
had actually hurt himself sometimes
you've got to create your own fun when
you're waiting around in between takes
number three not as efficient as one
might think they obviously needed wind
and waves during those scenes when
they'd be on the raft and there would be
occasions when we'd have huge wind
machines and wave machines going but
sometimes they would have to go old
school because the machines would make
too much noise and other times when it
would just be guys with buckets of water
throwing the water Adams Charlie Vickers
had a hard time just swimming in general
regardless of the simulated storm they
simulated a storm what you see on screen
is an exaggerated version of what we're
going through it was definitely
physically challenging I swim quite a
bit but I'm not a really amazing swimmer
number four not only were they fully
practical but the cast was pretty
terrified of them the makeup Department
spent hours perfecting their look well
before any of the other cast members had
even woken up you're getting in there at
7am being like gosh it's so early and
the Orcs been there since half midnight
the actors who played them were all
super friendly but morphod Clark admits
she was actually scared of them it was
really frightening she didn't even need
to act I feel like really lucky that we
got to actually be terrified by very
nice people but in settings a great
moment for her was working a scene with
them and being terrified and then
catching them eating lunch during their
break number five one of the toughest
new skills the cast had to pick up I
find water really frightening which is
why I was quite scared for the dive
drink luckily they had an incredible
team of trainers showing them the way of
the water we did lots of training with
amazing people yeah some amazing people
at the top of their game even with this
team of A-list trainers it was still one
of the most difficult challenges they
had to master they hope that all their
training shows up on screen because
without it they wouldn't have been able
to perform any of the sequences in the
sundering Seas number six it might seem
fun but they were extremely difficult to
stay balanced on I'd fall over quite a
lot and fall through the cracks in the
rain even behind the scenes the chaos
still ensues a lot of the crew were
using paddle boards in the water and one
of the directors of Photography was
struggling with their balance when the
dops fell love their um paddleboard oh
yeah that was funny it makes sense why
they had so many weeks of water training
number seven it was a never-ending
experience they had to be professionally
trained so they could learn to hold
their breath for at least a few minutes
in the beginning they would start by
trying to master up to 25 seconds and
then gradually push to get a few minutes
underwater morphid Clark describes it as
it doesn't get easier you just get more
used to ignoring the pain we spent so
long because it was such a complex
sequence they would switch from a big
outdoor tank to a five meter Deep dive
tank we spent weeks and weeks out there
into two different locations number
eight that hot New Zealand weather
really took a toll on the actors though
it was wonderful to have natural light
while shooting the actors really needed
to pack some extra SPF it's so glary and
you're surrounded by sort of like a
backdrop of course the backdrop was
white so it would reflect the sun right
back at them them they couldn't escape
it throughout the entire shoot one thing
they liked about being outside was the
fact that it really did give them the
impression that they were out there on
isolated water the tank was really that
big because it was so big you could
suspend your displays that it kept on
going number nine dwarves elves humans
and harfoots all different heights how
did they do it yeah apparently it wasn't
easy and involved a dizzying array of
camera tricks different size props actor
doubles and a headache inducing amount
of math that consumes everybody in the
scene just a simple scene involving a
dwarf and an elf walking down a hallway
was one of the most difficult scenes to
capture from the original script they
actually ended up switching it to a mine
shaft elevator which was still
incredibly difficult to pull off number
10. there are always a few onset
injuries quite a few stunt performers
got their fair share of pain but one in
part particular was Dana Grant who
suffered a pretty serious head injury it
was definitely a freak accident as she
regularly performs dangerous stunts in
Productions like Mad Max Wonder Woman
and many many other movies she's
probably more comfortable being on fire
than anyone you've ever met but due to a
misplaced bolt she hit her head when
taking a dive into one of the dive tanks
she was diagnosed with an eight
millimeter brain aneurysm and an injury
to her upper spine and had to get
emergency brain surgery concerned fans
ended up raising money so she would be
able to get the surgery she needed
number 11. there was always a
performance to watch we did sing a lot
markella Kavanaugh and Megan Richards
were constantly performing for the cast
we would be saying something they had
quite a reputation and one of the um
hair makeup artists was just like oh
I've heard about this apparently they're
both fantastic singers so nobody ever
complained about it one of their
favorite favorite songs they would
perform together was the best by Bonnie
Tyler also very notably covered by Tina
Turner number 12. another show that was
almost shut down by covid-19 the first
episode of the Season holds a special
place in morphod Clark's heart because
they had to stop Midway due to the
spread of kovid the show started filming
in New Zealand and at the time New
Zealand was taking serious precautions
to protect itself from the virus it was
mandated that everyone entering the
country including returning citizens had
to self-isolate most of the cast was
unsure if they would be able to come
back coming back to film it was just so
wonderful
rings of power definitely wasn't an easy
show to pull off we wouldn't have been
able to do what we did without that
training yeah
but with a stellar team behind all of
these camera tricks painful stunts
intense water training and insanely
realistic Prosthetics the dedicated Lord
of the Rings fan base will definitely
have a lot to digest by the end of it we
were really excited about that the whole
time yeah